we have any Batman fans here I just a
second ago I asked any football fans not
a single clap Batman overwhelming
applause yeah well some of you may know
this a new movie about Batman's
archenemy the Joker is apparently in the
works has been this story's been getting
a lot of coverage and over the weekend
the first official image of actor
Joaquin Phoenix in character as the
Joker was released I am NOT making this
up here's the actual photo blocking
Phoenix as the Joker I'm serious that's
the photo we're not doing a bit that's
the photo they release yeah yeah show it
again of Joaquin Phoenix as the Joker
now just to be clear the last time we
saw the Joker was when Jared Leto played
him in Suicide Squad here he is and of
course here's the Joker now in his
latest incarnation anyway as you can
imagine a lot of fans were sort of
underwhelmed when they saw that image of
Joaquin Phoenix well I'm just not sure
they're gonna be happy about some of the
other new images from the Joker movie
that were released just about an hour
ago for instance here's the first look
at the Joker 'mobile this is apparently
yeah that's yeah and here's how that
Joker's gonna spend his days wreaking
havoc around Gotham City this is how
he's going to do it actually yeah of
course it wouldn't be a joke or film
without some cameos from other DC
characters like Joker's pals Catwoman is
in the film the Riddler is in the movie
yeah and he'll be up against Batman
watch out for Batman yeah yeah and of
course this room will also feature the
iconic bat signal as the newest version
so
[Applause]
you